the real secret of everything comes from
this yellow pet hey guys welcome to my
nighttime routine I'm gonna be sharing
with you everything that I do before I
go to sleep as well as the scientific
reasoning for why I do it
I'm trying to get the best night's sleep
possible I want to drive down my anxiety
levels especially during a stressful
time and finally three I want to get
myself ready to face tomorrow as the
best version of myself before we get
started let's give a huge shout out to
Sensodyne for sponsoring this video
we're starting in the bedroom the
bedroom bedroom bedroom the reason why
I'm starting here even though it's not
bedtime just yet is because I want to
prep my sleep environment to be ready by
the time I get to bed I really focus on
three things here temperature humidity
and light levels these all need to be
set ahead of time preferably two three
hours so by the time you get to bed
you're not rolling around trying to fall
asleep that's gonna peak your anxiety
and anxiety is the enemy of good sleep
the first thing I do is I set the
temperature I ideally look for 65
degrees Fahrenheit the reason I do this
is cuz your body naturally lowers its
core temperature while you sleep so if
you can assist in the process by
lowering the environment temperature
you're gonna be doing yourself a favor
if you don't and it's warm in your room
your body's gonna try and cool down by
sweating and have you ever slept in
sweaty sheets that's a bad night's sleep
next I flip on my humidifier the air can
get quite dry in my apartment because I
am running the a/c and dry air really
irritates the nasal passageways leading
to congestion scratchy throat chapped
lips it's really difficult to get a good
night's sleep that way and I actually
recommend a humidifier to many of my
patients in order to keep their mucus
membranes voiced to potentially a
decrease the likelihood of them getting
a virus
the last piece to the puzzle is to get
rid of all external sources of light and
to make that happen I have to close my
blackout shades scientific research has
actually shown that even small sources
of light can make it difficult for you
to fall asleep
and to stay asleep I've made it a
complete blackout situation in my room
and I've really noticed the difference
over the last year or two we've wrapped
up in the bedroom let's take it to the
bathroom first things first
getting rid of the facial hair now I
used to shave before but then I realized
it made me look way too young to be a
doctor I kept getting those comments for
my patients there Doogie Howser who is
too much so now I use a beard trimmer
and really get that hair nice
short as well as using a shaver in order
to get rid of the scruff around my neck
I think it still looks professional but
at the same time it's a pretty aesthetic
look next I want to give you a sneak
peek at my skincare routine generally I
like to keep it pretty simple with a
Murad cleanser followed by a moisturizer
but on other days I'd like to get a
little fancy and I'm going to show you
that whole process when I do a dedicated
skincare video people look out for that
last but certainly not least is taking
care of these pearly whites look your
oral health is intimately connected to
the health of the rest of your body
we've actually seen with scientific
research that those who have poor oral
health have poor cardiovascular outcomes
as well you got to brush your teeth at
least twice a day something you may not
know about me is that I have really
sensitive teeth I've had braces twice in
my life whiten my teeth probably once
too much and because of that it's quite
painful to drink cold liquids like those
cookies and cream milkshakes something
I've been doing to combat it is using
sensitized sensitivity and gum
toothpaste because it truly helps this
is targeted for people who have
sensitive teeth or gum problems it's
actually the number one dentist
recommended brand for sensitive teeth
definitely check it out can't forget to
feed the new now then you just gotta
poop walking the new during quarantine
this is actually my favorite part of my
nighttime routine because it really
helps me wine down it's dark it's quiet
nobody's out the goes down except you
the bear finally peeps
now it's time for me to go upstairs and
share with you a couple of secrets that
I do to lower my anxiety before bed this
is when my wine down truly begins and
I'm gonna take you through the few steps
that I have laid out here of things you
need to do in order to get into bed and
fall asleep really quickly first things
first I know the lights in here aren't
that dim because I have the lights of
recording with but generally I only have
that light and that light on to keep it
dim so that when I get to bed my
melatonin levels are at their highest
point melatonin is a sleepiness hormone
that gets released when it's dark it's
part of your natural circadian rhythm so
the last thing you want to do is turn on
all the lights right before you go to
sleep and hurt that melatonin release
you want to keep down as high as
possible second I have my sleepy time
tea here I love green tea but green tea
has caffeine you don't want to consume
caffeine before bed
even if you're able to fall asleep it's
not a good idea because it'll interrupt
the stages of your sleep and you're
gonna wake up feeling not refreshed so
my sleepy time tea is chamomile no
caffeine it's an herbal tea there's
something relaxing about it I love it
it's my go-to drink next the real secret
of everything comes from this yellow pad
it's nothing to do with this yellow pad
it's just where I'm gonna write down the
next things I'm about to tell you first
create a to-do list for the following
day because the last thing you want to
do is get into bed and start thinking
all I have to remember to do this this
and this that's gonna keep you up get it
down on paper get it out of your mind
second I'm gonna tell you about the
three good things the three good things
is something I've wanted to tell you for
the longest time I wanted to make a
video dedicated to it because I'm so
excited about the three good things it's
actually a process meant to decrease
anxiety and depressive symptoms for up
to six months and all it takes is every
night before you go to sleep so grab a
yellow bowl or a non yellow pen or your
phone and to write down three good
things that have happened to you that
day as well as a brief reason as to why
for example for me number one I'll say
bear listen to me and the reason will be
lots of training it could be something
as small as that it could be something
as big as your family member had a
graduation you met someone someone held
a door for you in the supermarket or
yummy meal it doesn't matter as long as
it's positive the reason we're doing
this is we're retraining our minds to
let go of the anxiety and think about
the good things our minds naturally have
a baseline level of anxiety that's how
our ancestors survived but now it's much
safer you know we're living in homes
where there are no natural predators so
we need to think about the positive
things less so about the anxious things
the patients that I've recommended this
to say it's a true game changer I stand
behind it they stand behind it and it's
been researched in psychiatric medical
journals saying that it truly does work
come on it's bedtime for me but I'm
gonna leave you with three things that I
recommend you do not do before going to
bed first thing cell phone get the cell
phones away from you if you need to scan
for urgent emails from work or messages
that's fine but don't go on social media
check out what your ex is doing get FOMO
that's gonna peak your anxiety levels
definitely don't do that
second avoid heavy conversation you know
you get into bed with your partner and
you're like why didn't you like what I
was wearing you're gonna be worn out
you're gonna have low willpower you're
not gonna give the proper amount of time
to discuss the matter so save it for the
next day and for number three no news in
bed there's so much anxiety that's gonna
be passed on to you from there it's
gonna make it impossible to fall asleep
save that for the morning and you have
your coffee your tea you're ready to go
and face the day and I can't go to bed
without saying goodnight to the new
goodnight little puppy good night good
night good night yeah leave your
questions down below and as always stay
happy and healthy and sleepy thanks
again to Sensodyne for sponsoring this
video
[Music]